is there a way for the digital
experiences that we create to truly
enrich our physical lives that digital
culture would be described today as an
augmented reality metaverse we could use
this tool to Simply cover the world or
we could use it to further connect us to
this world you could leave a digital
artwork on the street corner for your
lover to find you could reinvent your
backyard with an animated treasure hunt
for your kids and their friends the
digital worlds we build can be a
wonderful playground for exploring
identity for learning new skills for
practicing creativity and bringing our
communities together